you're not bringing that girl here
Troy's father was yelling and even
though Troy curled his body down as
small as it would go burrowing under the
covers and clapping his hands over his
ears the man's voice still resonated
through his head like the toll of a
great Bell your father's right Troy
mother had gotten into the act - and
even though Troy couldn't see her from
his position he could imagine her glassy
pursed lips her deeply furrowed brow we
don't even know this girl and you know
what happened those other times Troy had
a feeling his older sister would chime
in next and he was not disappointed how
could you even get a girl anyway
Zeus sneered as Troy pressed his palms
harder against the side of his head
trying to block out the sounds you sure
you didn't pay this one Troy I felt a
single tear trickled down his cheek and
in its weight came a hatred made
stronger by the knowledge of his fierce
love for them his family his eternal
tormenters their voices were all mixed
together now raining down on him from
above hemming him in with their ridicule
until he was closed into an atom sized
box that he could see no escape from he
might have screamed but because of the
din of mingled shouts he couldn't be
sure he pushed at his temples as hard as
he dared making flash bulbs of white
light explode into the darkness behind
his eyes he knew they would stop
berating him eventually knew there would
be blessed silence after they'd
exhausted their vocabularies have
discussed for him but in the meantime
there was only noise and pain infinite
in its intensity he wasn't sure how much
time had passed when the voices finally
started to dwindle perhaps only minutes
had gone by
perhaps lifetimes slowly Troy removed
his hands from his ears the fingers were
numb and sluggish feeling as though they
belonged to someone else
he pulled the covers away from his face
and opened one eye a crack peering into
the gloomy dusk of his bedroom everyone
was gone and quiet reigned at last the
only sounds he could hear now were the
reassuring hum of the central
air-conditioning and the distant buzz of
a plane passing overhead he sighed and
fell back against the pillows letting
the cool air from the vents
a layer of sweat on his skin his family
was upset he knew but he also knew that
they would soon get over it they would
have to Sonia was coming tomorrow and
when they met her all their negative
feelings would evaporate they would love
her just as Troy loved her and perhaps
in her glow they would come to see Troy
himself in a different light she's
already on her way he whispered to his
empty room hugging himself with his long
pale arms wait until you all see her
candy Ratner otherwise known as Sonia
Andropov a-- threaded her way through
the airport a large duffel bag slung
over one shoulder she just flown in from
Cleveland but she had to hustle over to
the International Terminal
where the SAP was picking her up she
told him she was arriving from Moscow
and of course he'd bought it why
shouldn't he as she walked she practiced
some Russian phrases under her breath
paying special attention to her accent
in her experience Americans were
generally not very observant about
languages as long as she sounded
suitably exotic Pelle most of them
wouldn't know a Russian word if it bit
them on the ass but each new scam was
different and one could never be too
careful
kandi hopped on the tram that ran
between terminals holding onto the
silver bar with both hands and ignoring
the appreciative glances of the rumpled
businessmen leaning against the back of
the car she knew she was beautiful her
body tall and live her olive skin
flawless her abundant black hair swept
dramatically back from her sculptured
face she suppose she enjoyed the
attention to a point but deep down she
understood that her appearance was
simply a tool of her trade a means to an
end she stretched cat lake giving the
businessmen a show then switched her
back to the other shoulder the tram
shuddered to a halt and kandi
disembarked moving smoothly through the
crowd on her long legs her dark eyes
scanned the signs and when she saw one
pointing toward the main terminal she
headed down a carpeted gangway her
jeweled sandals shabby in a few years
out of style slapping against her heels
she glanced at her watch and frowned her
flight from Cleveland had been delayed
but she still thought she could make it
to the meeting point before Troy did
sighing she thought of her latest mark
she had never met him before of course
their most in-depth conversations had
occurred over messenger she'd never even
heard his voice he had emailed her
pictures of himself though he was a
handsome young man a little intense
not that it particularly mattered to her
what any of them looked like he had also
sent her pictures of his house and these
she had scrutinized with great interest
the guy was clearly loaded or at least
his parents were she remembered sitting
in front of the computer in her to room
Cleveland apartment grinning from ear to
ear as she stared at that marvelous
spread if she could pull off this one
gig she had thought to herself then
maybe she'd be able to retire from the
racket for good there was a large
fountain in the middle of the terminal
it's blue water spewing foam high above
the heads of the passing travelers it's
rushing roar muffling all sound within a
hundred-yard radius kandi scanned the
fountains marble lip searching for a
lanky sandy haired figure whose facial
expression would suggest expectation
desperation and perhaps just the
faintest touch of shame she saw no one
and her tense muscles relaxed a little
she felt around in her pants pocket
coming up with a crumpled $10 bill then
ducked into a nearby Starbucks for a
latte to drink while she waited
Troi spotted his beautiful bride at once
she was even more radiant than he had
hoped her tot figure perched gracefully
on the edge of the fountain her demure
profile seeming to shimmer against the
dull gray backdrop of the passers-by she
was drinking coffee and peering down at
an open book in her lap a closer
inspection revealed it to be an English
phrase book for a moment Troy was loath
to approach her afraid she would twinkle
out of existence like the crystalline
Falls of water that framed her angelic
form so much was riding on this meeting
what would mother and father say they
hadn't come with him but he could still
hear their scornful voices echoing in
his head he clenched his fist by his
sides and straightened his back
quickening his pace he would make his
family accept Sonya as his wife that was
all there was to it she was right there
in front of him like a dream become
flesh she was perfect
candy felt his presence before she saw
him when she looked up he was standing
no more than two feet away from her
leaning slightly forward his expression
a little dazed she was taken aback at
his sudden nearness but managed a quick
smile you are Troy she said in her
practice broken accent there was a
longer pause than was warranted and
candies in her alarm seemed poised to
jingle warning her to abort the mission
which was how she always thought of
these deals but finally after what
seemed like an eternity in which the
pounding water of the fountains served
as the only distraction
Troy answered yes she smiled again more
broadly hoping to conceal the uneasiness
that it sprouted in her stomach she
couldn't give up on this one she thought
it might be her ticket out she felt like
she should say something more to him but
she couldn't think of a single thing we
go she asked at last not wanting to
sound too eager but wanting to fill the
pounding silence up with words
however meaningless yes Troy seemed to
snap out of whatever trance had held him
and he began looking around at her feet
do you have any other bags candy scowled
prettily as if trying to parse the
sentence he just uttered then brightened
as pretended understanding dawned she
padded the duffle bag by her side this
is only bag
Troy's face seemed to sag a little at
bat but he quickly recovered holding out
his hand here I'll carry it for you she
let him take it then got to her feet she
was nearly the same height as he was as
he headed for the signs marked parking
garage she kept a few steps behind him
smiling brilliantly whenever he glanced
over his shoulder at her which was
unsettling Lee often candy studied him
as they made their way out of the
terminal he was a little thinner than
his pictures had suggested but clearly
in good physical shape he was clean and
well-groomed his slacks and a white
dress shirt freshly pressed he given his
age as 25 but to candy he seemed a
little younger than that earnest and
eager to please they reached the parking
garage neither having spoken candy gazed
admiringly at the pearl-grey infinity as
troy loaded her bag into the trunk he
came around and opened the door for her
which she thought was very sweet as she
got into the passenger seat she rewarded
him by lifting her skirt with a subtle
hand motion exposing a few inches of
smooth upper thigh they exchanged few
words on the drive candy was afraid of
giving too much away of slipping up in
her finely crafted persona and Troy for
his part simply seemed nervous he
adhered strictly to the speed limit she
noticed and his knuckles were white on
the steering wheel after about 40
minutes of silence was not even a radio
playing softly to fill the gap the
uneasy feeling began creeping into candy
stomach again she opened her mouth to
say something anything when suddenly
Troy flipped on his blinker and turned
off the road onto a narrow paved track
surrounded by thick overhanging trees he
turned toward her in the ensuing dimness
almost there he said she smiled and
nodded forgetting about making small
talk in her eagerness to see her new
surroundings
she leaned forward a little in her seat
peering intently through the windshield
a house when it emerged from the dense
foliage was far more fantastic than she
had imagined it was a palace plain and
simple
comparable to those sprawling English
country estates she'd always lusted
after in those old Merchant Ivory movies
there was an enormous pond in front
grown over with algae but still dazzling
with a stone statue of a cherubic boy in
its centre frolicking under a fountain
of water that no longer flowed the
gardens were extensive if a little
overgrown the flowerbeds needed weeding
and some of the hedges were due for a
prune but otherwise the expanse was
magnificent and then there was the house
itself
candy couldn't help gaping at it as Troy
guided the car around the circular
gravel driveway the main structure was
made of softly glowing stone of a
speckled caramel color that blended
organically with the surroundings there
appeared to be a massive center hub
flanked by two wings each with an
octagonal tower topped with distressed
cast elations there were numerous small
square windows many of them bearing
intricate stained-glass designs the
entire spread bore the unmistakable aura
of vast wealth and power after a few
moments candy became aware that Troy had
stopped the car and turned in his seat
to look at her with his rather unnerving
Lea open expression she could see that
he wanted very much to please her that
was good very good do you like it
he asked candy was so overwhelmed by her
unbelievable luck that she almost forgot
to speak with a Russian accent
catching herself just in time she said
it is so beautiful I did not know
America looked like this Troy laughed
and there was a hard edge to it that
candy didn't like most of it doesn't but
this is your home now
your life he smiled widely and his teeth
were very white in the shadows of the
car's interior
if the outside of the house was beyond
imagination then the inside was almost
surreal as she entered through the
carved wooden doors she felt like an
aunt who had just stumbled over the
threshold of Notre Dom the ceilings
soared high above her inlaid with
complicated tile patterns and
alternating colors of polished stone she
held her breath afraid that even the
sound of a sigh would bounce back to
deafen her I'll take your bag upstairs
Troy said his voice coming from all
directions at once you can look around
some if you want to don't get lost
though that predatory smile again I will
just sit in here she said gesturing to a
sitting room on her left she didn't want
to admit it but the sheer vastness of
the house frightened her she had
targeted quite a few rich guys in her
time but none of them had been this rich
she felt as though she might pass out at
any moment is OK
Troy shrugged sure when I come back down
I'll make us some tea and we can talk
later on I'll give you a tour and then
you can meet the family
Kandee nodded and watched as he
disappeared up the curving staircase
with its iron banisters when he gone she
wandered into the sitting-room which was
filled to brimming with fussy
claw-footed furniture that looked as
though it had never been sat on she
poked into a couple of the drawers and
hi boys
but found nothing of interest a few of
the vases in the corners looked terribly
expensive
perhaps they were Ming or something like
that there was even gold flocked
wallpaper of all things
candy stepped toward the wall for a
closer look and noticed that there were
lighter gold rectangles at even
intervals along the walls as though
pictures had once hung there she
wondered what they had been and why they
had been removed a few moments later she
heard raised voices and ducked her
shoulders guiltily before realizing they
were coming from upstairs she crept back
out into the hallway to listen removing
her shoes on the way so their heels
wouldn't flap an echo she couldn't
really tell what was being said but she
heard Troy a Reedy defensive line and
then another male voice deeper
authoritative there were women's voices
too one or two of them candy wasn't sure
she assumed the family was not too
pleased about her arrival
and her uneasiness ramped up another few
notches surely Troy had worked all this
out before arranging for her to come
here she hoped this whole gig was going
to run smoothly she hadn't really
bargained on uncooperative relatives
sticking their noses in the voices died
down and then she heard footsteps
reverberating over her head she darted
back into the sitting room and installed
herself on the edge of one of the SETI's
snatching an architectural magazine from
an end table and pretending to leap
through it when Troy appeared on the
threshold she looked up expectantly as
if she'd been waiting for him all along
okay she said she didn't want him to
know what she had heard it might
complicate matters his jaw seemed tight
but otherwise he gave no outward sign of
distress your things are in one of the
guest rooms for now he said and then his
face reddened as he realized the
implications of his statement I mean
there are lots of empty rooms you can
stay in whichever one you want he
grinned awkwardly then made a stiff
gesture for her to follow him
we'll have tea out on the sundeck after
flashing him a look of pleasant
blackness as though she hadn't the
foggiest idea what he was talking about
she began trailing along behind him soon
losing all sense of direction in the
maze of twisting corridors at last they
entered a kitchen big enough to park a
747 in and Troy set to work pulling cups
and saucers from one of a long phalanx
of cabinets candy wondered why they were
no servants but she thought it better
not to ask just yet while he worked
candy made her way down the small
hallway he'd indicated which terminated
in a pair of blue glass doors
she opened these and proceeded out onto
a huge wooden deck that overlooked part
of the gardens candy sat at one of the
umbrella covered tables staring out at
the early fall blossoms and wondering
what in the hell she'd gotten herself
into
after tea and an awkward conversation in
which the main thing candy learned about
her future husband was that he was the
most socially inept person she had ever
met troy cleaned up the dishes and led
candy on a rather perfunctory tour of
the house the doors of most of the rooms
were closed and stayed closed usually
with Troy explaining that the rooms were
empty are only used for storage the
house was vast and beautiful and candy
tried to work up the requisite
enthusiasm as she followed him around
but the flight and the stress of
beginning a new con had finally caught
up with her I am sorry Troy she said
haltingly I am very tired maybe finish
another time a deep thunderous frown
crossed his face so quickly that candy
wasn't even sure if she had seen it
that's all right he said taking her arm
gently and leading her back down the
hallway they just traversed you can rest
in your room for a while if you want
then later we'll have some dinner and
meet the family if they're around candy
stomach lurched at the prospect but she
only nodded and let herself be led
through the already unfamiliar corridors
at last Troy stopped before a door
opened it and guided her inside
for one uncomfortable moment it seemed
as though he was going to follow candy
into the room but with a jolt he stopped
just a few paces over the threshold
he stood there fists opening and closing
by his side's thank you said candy
hoping he'd take the hint too tired to
even look around at her new digs
after a moment Troy bowed his head at
her once formally like a butler then
turned and left the room closing the
door behind him candy let out a sigh of
relief immediately making for the
massive bed that dominated one corner of
the room slipping off her shoes and
setting them next to the duffel bag that
Troy had brought up earlier she wondered
if he had looked through it then decided
she didn't much care if he had let the
sad bastard get a few jollies sifting
through her unmentionables she thought
with a wry grin she stretched out on the
bed which was almost criminally
comfortable if a tad musty-smelling
she thought she'd fall asleep right away
but she just lay there aching muscles
slowly unfurling but her exhausted brain
refusing to settle
she assessed her situation first of all
this was the biggest con by far that
she'd ever attempted and she had to
fight the vaguely queasy feeling that
she was in way over her head the con
would work the same she told herself how
rich the guys were didn't matter and one
look at handsome sheltered Troy
convinced her that he'd be a piece of
cake to manipulate he was clearly
desperate for a woman she speculated
that he might be a virgin which would
make her job even easier she was worried
about his family though from the sound
of their shrieking this afternoon she
deduced that they were none too pleased
with this whole situation with her
presence here if they were able to get
to him to poison him against her but no
she couldn't let that happen
she just had to play it cool be nice as
pie to the family when she met them but
then tried to subtly undermine their
influence whenever she was alone with
Troy make it seem like it was him and
her against his meddling relations yes
that was the smartest way to play it
she'd have to be careful that she didn't
get the idiot disowned but hopefully
she'd have made the haul and taken off
before things got to that point
candy slowly realized that the same
shouting she'd heard earlier had started
again she'd been so lost in thought that
she hadn't noticed it so for all she
knew it could have been going on for a
while still tired but galvanized by
curiosity she slid off the bed and crept
toward the door pressing her ear against
the wood listening it was the deep male
voice speaking which she assumed
belonged to Troy's father candy can only
make out random phrases and stray words
but the man's tone was one of obvious
rage but also she thought a hint of
resignation how is it different
the man bellowed and candy could almost
imagine Troy cowering under the
authority of that booming voice she
heard Troy uttering something
unintelligible that ended with marry me
then he said she'll I asked
Kandee cursed under her breath what did
he meant by all that she'll do whatever
I ask
her frown deepened man if he thought
that he was dealing with the wrong
Russian mail-order bride
the father was speaking again louder we
can't for you he said and candy clenched
her fists in frustration what the hell
were they saying there was another
exchange that she caught none of and
then there was the definite sound of a
door slamming and heavy footsteps coming
closer through the hallways quickly a
candy climbed back onto the bed and
feigned sleep a moment later there was a
firm knock on the bedroom door she
thought if she ignored it the Troy would
go away but the knocking persisted angry
and strangely fearful she got up again
and slipped back into her shoes because
it seemed vulgar to converse and ones
bare feet at a house as grand as this
one and opened the door it was not Troy
who stood there this man seemed taller
and broader with a strong resemblance to
Troy but with something harder behind
the eyes the blond hair was shot through
with grey the skin around the eyes and
mouth darkened by fine wrinkles your
Sonya he said it wasn't a question
Kandee thought it odd that he had
addressed her by her first name but she
let it go yes and you were here to marry
my son
the flinty eyes narrowed ticking in her
face her body her entire being kandi
hesitated her mind racing but then said
if your son will accept me she lowered
her gaze and then raised it again like a
deferential bow
this seemed to be the correct answer
because the man's features visibly
softened his eyes still glinted like
steel though you may have noticed that
my son is a little shy he was seemingly
embarrassed to be discussing something
as feminine as emotions he's had his
problems I'll admit that but I hope that
this time he's found someone who can
relate to him someone who will stick
around
candy remembered to look pained to pause
as though struggling to understand the
language yes she said thinking that the
man's use of the phrase this time
pointed to her not being the first
wondering how much harder that was going
to make matters I think I will like Troy
the man brightened and suddenly he
seemed much younger more like a man than
a knob Durrett brick wall he even
reached toward her briefly before
catching himself glancing in horror at
the hand that had seemingly betrayed him
then he backed up a few steps before
turning and lumbering down the hall not
saying another word
chandi closed the bedroom door disturbed
and relieved in equal measure she was
glad to see that Troy's father wasn't
the ogre she'd been expecting but that
strange gesture just now when he'd
wanted to touch her she shook her head
she'd have to watch herself around him
that was certain the exhaustion hit her
again more insistent this time so not
even bothering to take off her shoes she
flopped across the bed and was asleep in
an instant
Troy was rooting around in the Attic
sneezing uncontrollably at the clouds of
dust he was kicking up sending squealing
rodents from corners with his clumsy
maneuvering he wasn't worried about the
noise he was making Sonja's room was two
floors below in the opposite wing and
besides when he peeked in on her earlier
she had been sound asleep Troy tried to
put the image of the beautiful Sonya
stretched across the bedclothes out of
his mind
so that he could concentrate on the task
at hand he knew the key to the special
room was around here somewhere he had
kept it well hidden for years saving it
for the momentous occasion of his
marriage he poked his fingers into the
drawer of an antique jewelry box but
came up with nothing except dust and the
desiccated carcass of a dead silverfish
scowling he wiped his hands on his
trousers and opened the next drawer
nothing there either he was being too
worried that someone had moved the key
but who could have possibly done that
nobody knew about it but him nobody came
up to the attic but him he had just
forgotten where he put it that was all
he was always miss placing things and
anyway it was a long time ago at last he
came across the key in the bottom of an
empty violin case tucked under a flap of
decaying velvet he didn't remember
putting it there but that didn't matter
now curling the rusty metal into his
fist he made his way to the narrow
staircase leaving the attic and disarray
behind him once back in the hallway he
found himself so excited that he
couldn't keep from running down the
carpeted corridors taking the servants
stairs down from the third floor to the
second his special room was in the very
farthest corner of the East Wing a large
oval chamber that looked out into the
closed in back garden he tried to
picture it now as he hurried toward it
tried to set it in his mind before he
saw it to test himself over the years he
had lovingly assembled every piece of
furniture every tiny detail in the room
in preparation for his wedding night he
can hardly believe the day was almost
here his heart felt as big as a bass
drum in his chest
at last breathing hard he reached the
door to the room that he would share
with his wife he had always kept it
locked even when the maids had been here
they had been under strict orders never
to enter it Troy was the only one
allowed inside once he had arranged it
to his satisfaction he had sealed it up
tight only checking it every three
months or so cleaning and airing out he
thought a ceremonial pause would be in
order but his excitement was too great
he thrust the key into the lock and
turned it simultaneously pushing the
door inward and breathing in the scent
of the place the enchanting combined
fragrance of roast wood and iron old
incense and fresh industrial rubber
when candy awoke she had no idea where
she was for the first few minutes night
must have fallen the stained glass
windows were black behind their colors
she sat up in bed wincing at the pain
and her stiff neck and groped for the
lamp on the end table in its glow she
could see the secretive contours of the
room strange but slowly becoming
familiar
she caught a tang of perfume and
wondered if someone had looked in on her
after she had washed up in the adjoining
bathroom and changed into a clean dress
from her duffle bag she decided she'd
better track down her host the house
around her seemed deathly silent but she
supposed that wasn't surprising given
its great size perhaps the family had
gone out as soon as she was in the
hallway she caught the unmistakable
aroma of meat cooking and she quickened
her pace
suddenly ravenous it took her a few
false turns and dead ends but she
finally found the marble staircase
leading to the ground floor and from
there she followed her nose to the
kitchen a woman stood at the stove her
back facing candy this was Troy's mother
she presumed as the woman was also
blonde slim like Troy was with long
spindly arms and legs she apparently
hadn't heard candy come in for she
didn't turn candy cleared her throat
loudly and the woman jumped Oh Sonia the
woman smiled and wiped her hands on a
tea towel approaching candy with an open
friendly expression candy found it hard
to square this woman's demeanor with the
shrill harridan she'd heard berating
Troy earlier but maybe she was just very
good at hiding her true feelings you
startled me dear I'm Alice Troy's mother
Sonia and her Papa candy shook the
woman's hand very nice to meet so you're
from Russia
Alice glided back to the stove stirring
something in a large silver saucepan
what part
Moscow candy had considered telling the
mark she was from some remote part of
Russia some village with an
unpronounceable name but she found that
people were far more accommodating if
they'd heard the place she mentioned
besides she'd been to Moscow once as a
student so she figured she knew enough
about the place to bluff a little if she
had to ah lovely place Alice didn't say
any more about Russia and candy was glad
have you met Leonard Leonard is Troy's
father yes candy hesitated thinking of
how the man had come to her room yes she
said in hallway she twisted her hands
where is Troy she asked not really
because she cared but just trying to
make conversation
Alice continued stirring oh I'm sure
he's around you'll see him at dinner why
don't you go ahead and have a seat in
the dining room it felt like a dismissal
though the woman's friendly tone never
altered candy left the kitchen not
knowing exactly where the dining room
was but wandering around until she found
it there was a large table in the center
draped with white linen and a Pekka Blee
set for two people
candy confused slid into a chair before
one of the place settings wasn't the
whole family gonna eat together 20
minutes passed on the mantel clock as
she waited every now and then leaving
her seat to study the crystal bowls in
the china cabinet or to stare at one of
the long narrow windows at the overgrown
gardens
lit at this hour by spotlights mounted
on the side of the house finally she
heard a noise behind her and turned to
see not Alice but Troy his hot padded
hands bearing a huge ceramic bowl that
appeared to be filled with a thick stew
he smiled at her as he set the bowl in
the middle of the table then he reached
into his pocket and produced a Bic which
he used to light the two red candles in
the table centerpiece I'll just go get
the bread he told her and then
disappeared before candy could ask what
was going on when he returned he carried
a big basket filled with sliced bread
that smelled as though it had just come
out of the oven
candy felt her mouth watering she hadn't
had a decent meal in days please sit
down Troy said and as she did he
answered her unasked question I thought
it would be nice for just the two of us
to have dinner together the others will
eat later
candy thought this odd since she and
Troy had already had tea alone together
and found not a single thing to talk
about and since she hadn't been formally
introduced to the family at large but of
course she kept her mouth shut the rich
were eccentric she knew and this
family's quirks were really no weirder
than those of some of her other marks
they passed the meal and relative
silence Troy seemingly wanted to talk
but unable to think of anything to say
candy concentrating on the food and on
not giving herself away by saying
something stupid or out of character
at one point Troy attempted to start a
conversation about his childhood but it
sputtered out fairly quickly once candy
had finished two bowls of stew and four
slices of the thick bread she began to
feel sleepy again and ready to go back
upstairs to bed to this end she pushed
her chair away from the table and made
to excuse herself but then Troy very
suddenly announced we'll be married
tomorrow
she froze trying not to let the shock of
the statement show on her face so soon
she asked keeping her voice neutral
Troy's expression clouded over don't you
want to of course is OK candy smiled
placating hoping he didn't notice the
sweat that beaded upon her brow troy
seemed mollified it's all arranged he
said and his gaze grew distant as though
looking through reality to what lay
beyond I've even got a dress for you in
a special room for us
wait until you see it'll be perfect
candy nodded encouragingly then chugged
half a glass of water in one go trying
to quell the panic this was not in the
plan at all she'd never had any
intention of actually marrying this guy
what was she going to do marriage would
make everything legal make her and the
money easier to track down on the other
hand if she skipped out tonight she left
with nothing
she'd be abandoning what promised to be
the most lucrative score of her life
perhaps the one she could retire on her
head began to pound Troy was saying
something else but she wasn't really
listening she was so tired and she had
to think she held up her hand to silence
him please I am sorry I must go back to
bed now we will talk more in the morning
he looked to be getting angry again
so she hastily added I am very excited
to see the dress he was clearly still
wary but he smiled sure of course you
need your rest big day tomorrow
his smile stretched too disturbing
proportions yes candy got it from the
table goodnight Troy
goodnight darling candy skin crawled as
she made her way out of the dining room
and back through the perfusion of
corridors and staircases that eventually
led back to her room
once there she tried to lock the door
but found she had no key instead she
wedged a heavy upholstered chair against
the door and then sat down on the bed
thinking she was so exhausted that she
could hardly keep her eyes open but she
forced herself to stay awake she had to
figure out a plan it was obvious she had
to get the hell out of here as quickly
as possible she hated having to abort a
mission as potentially enriching as this
one but Troy was seriously weird if not
completely unhinged and things were
progressing to escape velocity too
quickly for her she wasn't sticking
around in order to get embroiled in
illegal
not to mention probably sexual bond with
the Freak downstairs and his elusive
family she yawned expansively then stood
up and began moving around why in the
hell was she so damn tired sluggishly
she set about gathering the few items
she'd taken out of her duffel bag and
repacking them she thought it best to
make her escape right away while Troy
was otherwise occupied in the kitchen
she didn't think he'd be able to hear
her leave she didn't have a car but she
remembered it wasn't far to the main
road once there she could call a taxi
and pay for it with the last of her cash
she'd have to charge a hotel room and
figure out what to do from there then an
idea managed to filter its way into her
muddled brain it occurred to her that
even though she was cutting the con
short before it had really begun
she still needn't leave with nothing
this house after all was chock full of
valuable knickknacks that could be
spirited away without anyone in the
family being the wiser a quick glance
around her own room showed nothing
promising but candy figured she could
poke her head in to a few rooms on her
way out slinging the duffel bag across
her shoulder and wincing at the creeping
numbness in her limbs candy pushed the
chair aside and listened at the door for
the sound of footsteps she heard nothing
but became alarmed when her head drooped
against the door her eyes closing of
their own accord she snapped awake not
knowing if she'd been out for a second
or an hour
what the hell was the matter with her
the horrible possibility dawn that Troy
might have put something in her food but
why would he do that as far as he was
concerned Sonya was here willingly and
raring to get hitched
no she had just eaten too much on top of
the jetlag and fatigue that was all she
eased the bedroom door open and looked
both ways down the hall which was lit
only by a few dim wall sconces the coast
seemed clear so she forced herself out
of the room closing the door gently
behind her
there were several doors on either side
of the hall all closed and to candy the
whole thing resembled nothing so much as
a fancy hotel corridor the first two
doors she tried were locked
the third opened onto a broom containing
nothing but an old sofa covered with a
plastic drop cloth Candy's feet dragged
along the carpet as she struggled to
stay upright her vision was even
starting to blur a little well she could
have a nap in the cab when she had
gotten out of this madhouse the next
room was empty except for a stack of
framed photos and paintings leaning so
the images faced the wall kandi
remembered the blank squares on the
wallpaper in the sitting room downstairs
and wondered if these were the pictures
that have been removed she considered
going in to look but she was so tired
and besides it seemed like a waste of
time
paintings weren't the most practical
objects to steal she closed the door
again the next two rooms were also
locked and kandi was considering simply
leaving the house empty-handed as
depressing a proposition as that was but
the next door the one adjacent to the
main staircase opened easily and a lamp
had been left burning within she swayed
on the threshold finally managing to
focus her vision this had to be Troy's
room there were his dress trousers
folded neatly over the back of the chair
and there was the only picture of
herself that kandi had ever sent him
blown up to poster size and pinned to
the wall above the headboard she
shuddered kandi stepped farther into the
room thinking maybe Troy had left some
cash or a fancy wristwatch lying around
as she approached the nightstand
something on the bed caught her eye
it was about the size of a cat and furry
at first she thought it was a dead
animal of some sort and her heart
skipped a beat
but as she peered closer she saw that it
was only a wig long and blonde and
startlingly realistic
despite her buzzy state candy had to
smile so that was one of Troy's dirty
little secrets was it funny she'd never
have pegged him as the transvestite type
her smile faded as she realized what lay
beside the wig there in a rumpled tangle
was a woman's blouse with red and white
stripes and a black denim skirt it was
the same outfit true his mother had been
wearing when candy had seen her in the
kitchen earlier that evening her Foggs
brain reeled what the hell kind of sick
Norman Bates [ __ ] was going on here her
terrified gaze slid away from the
clothes and settled on the dresser whose
surface was littered with cosmetics
men's and women's jewelry and a few
bottles of gray hair coloring hanging
from a peg above the dresser was another
wig this one a darker blonde and styled
in a perk Bob Troy had told her he had a
sister hadn't he Jesus Christ forgetting
the valuables she turned to run but her
legs had gone to jelly wobbling
threatening ly beneath her Troy stood in
the doorway beaming at her as though she
was the Virgin Mary
candy heard the duffel bag hit the floor
as it fell from her nerveless grasp then
she heard Troy say I see you're making
the family's acquaintance and then she
heard and saw no more
candy was aware of sounds and voices and
for a moment she thought she was back in
her apartment in Cleveland and that she
was dreaming and then suddenly reality
came flooding back I told you this one
was no different from the others hissed
a deep voice very close by they're all
the same didn't I tell you that she had
her bag Troy she was running away candy
didn't want to open her eyes the images
her mind was conjuring up were horrible
enough the feeling in her limbs had
returned enough for her to discern that
she was lying flat on her back and that
her wrists and ankles were restrained
but I got her to stay father that was
Troy's voice plaintive and childlike I
got mother to put some medicine in her
soup just to make sure it isn't going to
be like those other times I swear it
technically speaking none of those other
girls ever left either said a young
female voice chuckling sardonically stop
teasing him sue Alice admonished though
of course kandi knew who was really
speaking even without opening her eyes
Troy's mother went on all we want is for
this girl to work out we can't keep
covering up for you when they don't I
know mother I know exclaimed Troy
switching back to his regular voice
without a pause and I appreciate all
you've done for me but this is different
candy felt a hand on her arm and her
eyes flew open like a shot Troy was
standing over her looking down at her
with a rather frightening expression of
plainly psychotic devotion candy raised
her head as much as she was able
struggling against her bonds she was
clad in a stiff antique wedding dress
and shackled to what looked like a
hospital bed when she looked beyond
herself beyond the staring face at the
doting Troy and focused on her
surroundings
she nearly screamed the walls around her
were black and shiny like thick rubber
or vinyl covered pads worse than this
though were the metal instruments she
could see suspended from pegs around the
rooms oval perimeter the objects all had
long probing rods and sharp points
sticking out at odd angles and kandi
didn't even want to imagine where one
would insert them
she opened her mouth to speak but no
sound came out she struggled mightily
thinking if she could just get through
Detroit maybe she could talk him out of
whatever he was planning to do before
she could get a word out troy put a
finger gently to her lips I know what
you're going to say and I'm very sorry
about the slight change of plans but I
thought you weren't quite as
enthusiastic about the marriage as I
would have liked so I just gave you a
little encouragement he reached into his
pocket and now Candi noticed he was
dressed in an old-fashioned tuxedo that
smelled vaguely of mothballs
he opened his hand to show her the
object he had retrieved a thin gold band
with three squared diamonds mounted
side-by-side it was my wedding ring and
my mother's before that Troy said
Alice's voice emerging from his lips as
though he was possessed by a honey
throated demon candy cried out as Troy
slipped the ring onto her finger you
killed them
she said not bothering with the Russian
accent anymore you killed your whole
family Troy's eyebrows went up almost to
his hairline I'll have you know that I
my wife and my daughter sue are very
much alive he said in his Leonard voice
then he switched to the Alice voice with
a simultaneous change in demeanor we did
leave Troy alone for a while we admit
that Alice said was something that
sounded like regret but when we saw how
much he needed us well how could we stay
away
Troy smiled a feminine motherly smile
kandi couldn't stop the sobs from coming
now you're crazy
she said pushing and pulling against her
bonds all to no avail
Troy slapped her savagely across the
face don't ever say that he whispered
speaking as himself again he pointed to
the ring on her finger do you see that
you're my wife now Sonya and wives do as
their husbands asked I'm not your wife
candy screamed tears backing up in her
eyes blinding her my name's not even
Sonya and I'm not even Russian I'm from
[ __ ] Ohio her chest hitched and she
found it hard to catch her breath
this could not be happening there was
just no way listen to her poor dear said
the Alice voice yeah you sure she wanted
to marry you bro
added the HSU voice Troy's own
personality returned Sonya and I would
like to be alone now
he said tightly
there was a long pause then he regarded
his captive with something like real
affection they're gone now darling he
brushed her cheek where he had slapped
it as though trying to heal the wound
with his touch
then his finger skipped lightly over her
chin and her neck finally coming to rest
just at the swell of her breasts he
looked to be an ecstasy candy wanted to
close her eyes to make it all go away
but she didn't dare it's going to be
wonderful my love he said backing up a
few steps and shrugging out of his
tuxedo jacket those other girls before
they would do some of what I wanted go
part of the way with me but there was
always a point where they would want to
stop
he was unbuttoning his shirt now and
then removing it to reveal his pale
torso they were never as devoted to me
as a wife would be he went on and I
never brought them here to this room he
had stepped out of his pants and
underwear and stood before her his naked
form dimly reflected in the shiny black
walls you're the first one I ever
brought in here he said reverently
gesturing around the room at all the
instruments glimmering on their pegs
I've been waiting for this for so long
Troy grabbed a handful of Candy's skirt
and began shoving the lace and tulle
bundle up toward her thighs candy did
close her eyes then knowing it wouldn't
help but no longer wanting to see what
her fate would be in the darkness behind
the lids she pictured that first day
sitting by her computer answering that
stupid personal ad and looking forward
to another conquest another cache in
tears leaked from the corners of her
eyes she wished she was back there safe
and her single girl squalor she wished
she was anywhere she wished she was dead
candy heard a metallic clang as Troy
removed one of the instruments from the
wall and then heard his quickening
breath as he approached her preparing
himself to test the bonds of matrimony
candy clenched her teeth and hooked to
Christ her agony would be brief
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they met at Krupp and Mason's
musical instrument makers of Little
Britain ICI where Walter had been
employed two years and then came an e to
type and be serviceable they began to go
out together after six o'clock and when
mrs. Evans Annie's mother lost her
lodger and he mentioned it and Walter
went to live with them at number
thirteen call furred road north by which
time Annie and Walter might almost be
said to have been engaged his salary
however was only thirty shillings a week
he was the thorough cockney Walter a
well setup person of thirty strong
shouldered with a square brow a mustache
and black acne specs in his nose and
pale face it was on the night of his
arrival at number thirteen that he for
the first time saw Rachel Annie's
younger sister both girls in fact were
named Rachel after a much more another
of mrs. Evans
but Annie Rachel was called Annie and
Mary Rachel was called Rachel Rachel
helped Walter at the handle of his box
to the top back room and here in the
lamplight he was able to see that she
was a tallish girl with hair almost
black and with a sprinkling of freckles
on her very white fin nose on the tip of
which stood collected usually some
little sweats
she was thin faced and her top teeth
projected a little so that her lips only
closed with effort she was not so pretty
as pink and white little Annie though
one could guess at a glance that she was
a person more to be respected what do
you think of him said Annie meeting
Rachel as she came down he seems a nice
fellow
Rachel said rather good-looking and
strong in the back you bet Walter spent
that evening with them in the area front
room smoking a foul bulldog pipe which
slushed and gurgled to his suction and
at once mrs. Evans a dark old lady
without waist all size and lack of
breath decided that he was a gentlemanly
decent fellow
when bed time came he made the proposal
to lead them in prayer and to this they
submitted in a having for warned them
that he was a Christian as he climbed to
his room the devoted girl found an
excuse to slip out after him and in the
passage of the first floor there was a
little kiss
only one she said with an uplifted
finger and what about his little brother
then he chuckled a chuckle with which
all his jokes were accompanied a kind of
guttural chuckle which seemed to descend
or stick straining in the throat instead
of rising to the lips you go on
she said playfully tapped his cheek and
ran down so Walter slept for the first
night and mrs. Evans's on the whole as
time passed he had a good deal of the
Society of the women for the theater was
a thing abominable to him and in the
evenings he stayed in the underground
parlour sharing the bread and cheese
supper and growing familiar with the
size of mrs. Evans over her once a state
in the world Rachael the silent sewed
Annie whose relation with Walter was
still unannounced though perhaps guests
could play him tunes on the old piano
and she played last of all Walter laid
down the inveterate wet pipe led them in
prayer and went to bed most mornings he
and Annie set out together for Little
Britain there came a day when he
confided to her his intention to ask for
a raise and when this was actually
promised by his terror the boss it was
joy in heaven and radiance and Futurity
and secret talks of rings a wedding a
home and he felt herself not far from
the kingdom of hymen and rejoiced but
nothing as yet was said at number
thirteen for to mrs. Evans passed
grandeurs thirty shillings a week was
felt to be inappropriate the next Sunday
however soon after dinner this
strangeness occurred Rachel the silent
disappeared mrs. Evans called for her
Annie called but it was found that she
was not in the house though the putting
away of the dinner things her usual task
was only half accomplished not till
teatime did Rachel returned she was then
cold and somewhat sullen and somewhat
pale her lips closing firmly over her
projecting teeth when timidly questioned
for her resentment was greatly feared
she replied that she had just been
looking in upon Alice souls be a few
blocks away for a little chat and this
was the truth it was not however the
whole truth she had also looked in at
the church Lane sunday-school on her way
and this fact she guiltily concealed for
half an hour she had sat darkly at the
end of the building in a corner
listening to the address
a dress was delivered by Walter to the
school every Sunday after dinner he put
down the beloved pipe to go he was in
fact its superintendent after this the
tone and temper of the little household
rapidly changed and a true element of
hell was introduced into its platitude
it became first of all a question
whether or not Rachel could be
experiencing religion a thing which her
mother and Annie had never dreamt of
expecting of her praying people and the
salvation estado ways been the contempt
of her strong and callous mind but on
Sunday night she was now observed to go
out alone and Chapel was the explanation
which she coolly gave which chapels she
did not specify but in reality it was
the Newton Street Hall at which Walter
frequently exhorted and prayed in the
church Lane schoolroom there was prayer
meeting on Thursday evenings and twice
within one month
Rachel sallied forth on Thursday evening
soon after Walter the secret disease
which preyed upon the poor girl could
hardly now be concealed at first she
suffered bitter solitary shame sobbed in
a hundred paroxysms hoped to draw a veil
over her infirmity but her gash was too
glaring in the long Sabbath evenings of
summer he preached at street corners and
sometimes secretly sometimes openly
Rachel would attend these meetings
singing meekly with the rest the
undefined hymns of the modern evangelist
in his presence in the parlor on other
nights she quietly sewed hardly speaking
when at 7:00 p.m. she heard his key in
the front door her heart darted toward
its master when in the morning he flew
away to business her universe was
cinders it's a wonder to me what's
coming to her Rachel lately said Annie
in the train coming home you're doing
her soul good or something aren't you he
chuckled with slushy suction sounds
about the back of the tongue and molars
oh that be jiggered for a tale he said
she's alright I know her better than you
you see she's quite changed since you've
come looks to me as if she's having a
touch of the blues or something poor
thing she wants looking after don't she
Annie laughs to but less brutally more
uneasily Walter said but she oughtn't to
add the blues if she's giving her heart
to the Lord people seem to think a
Christian must be this in that
a Christian if it comes to that ought to
be the jolliest fellow going this was on
a Thursday the night of the church Lane
prayer meeting and Walter had only time
to rush in at number 13 wash his face
snatch his Bible and be off Rachel for
her part must verily now have been badly
bitten with the rabies of love or she
would have felt that to follow tonight
for the third time lately could not fail
to incur remark but this consideration
never even entered a mine now completely
blinded and entranced by the personality
of Walter
through the day her work about the house
had been rushed forward with this very
object and at the moment when he banged
the door after him she was before her
mirror dressing and blanched intense and
trembling flurry and casting is she bent
to give the last touches to her bangs a
look of bitterest hate at the projection
of her lip above the teeth this night
for the first time she waited in the
chapel till the end of the service and
walked slowly homeward on the way which
she knew that Walter would take and he
came striding presently his Bible in his
hand
nearly every passage in which was neatly
under ruled in black and red inks what
is that you he said taking into his a
hand cold with sweat it is she answered
in a hard formal tone you don't mean to
say you've been to the meeting I do why
where were my eyes I didn't see you it
isn't likely that you would want to
mister Teager
go on drop that what do you take me for
I'm only too glad and I tell you what it
is miss Rachel I say to you as the Lord
Jesus said to the young man thou art not
far from the kingdom of heaven she was
in it near him alone in a Darkling
square yet suffering too in the flames
of a passion such as perhaps consumes
only the strongest nature's she caught
for support at his unarmed and when he
bent his steps straight homeward she
said trembling violently I don't wish to
go home as yet I wish to have a little
walk do you mind mister Teager my no
come along then and they went walking
among an intricacy of streets and
squares he talking of the work and of
common subjects after half an hour she
was saying I often wish I was a man a
man can say and do what he likes but
with a girl it's different there's you
now mister Teager always out and about
having people listening to you and that
I often wish I was only a man
oh well it all depends how you look at
it he said and look here you may as well
call me Walter and be done oh I
shouldn't think of that she replied not
till her hand trembled on his arm well
out with it why don't you till we know
something more definite about you and
Annie he chuckled slush Lea she now
leading him fleetly round and round a
square eye you girls again he cried been
blabbing again like all the girls
it takes a bright man to hide much from
them don't it but there isn't much to
hide in this case as far as I can see is
there as always walter laughed
straining deep in the throat he said oh
come that would be telling wouldn't it
after a minute stillness this
treacherous phrase came from Rachael
Andy doesn't care for anyone mister
Teager that's rather a tall order anyone
she's alright but she doesn't of course
most girls are silly in that and like to
get married well that's only nature
ain't it this was a joke and downward
the laugh strained in his throat like
struggling phlegm yes but they don't
understand what love is said Rachel they
haven't an idea they'd like to be
married women and have a husband in that
but they don't know what love is believe
me the men don't either how she trembled
her body her dying voice she pressed
heavily upon him while the moon triumphs
now through cloud glaring a moment white
on the lunacy of her ghostly face well I
don't know I think I understand last
what it is he said you don't mr. Teager
how's that then because when it takes
you it makes you well let's have it
you seem to know all about it now Rachel
commenced to tell him what it was in
frenzied definitions and a power of
expression strange for her it was a
lunacy it's name was legion it was
possession by the Furies it was a spasm
in the throat and a sickness of the
limbs and a yearning of the eye whites
and a fire in the marrow
it was catalepsy trance apocalypse it
was high as the galaxy it was addicted
to the gutter
it was Vesuvius borealis the sunset it
was the rainbow in a cesspool it was a
Transfiguration and a leprosy and a
metempsychosis
neuroses it was the dance at the mean
ads and the bite of the tarantula and
baptism in a Sun outpoured the wild
definition in simple words but with the
strife of one fighting for life and she
had not half done when he understood her
fully and he had no sooner understood
her than he was subdued and succumbed
you don't mean to say he faltered Oh mr.
Teager she answered there's none so
blind as those who will not see his arm
stole around her shuddering body every
one is said to have his failing and this
man Walter in no respect a man of strong
mind was certainly on his amatory side
most sudden promiscuous and infirm and
this tendency was if anything heightened
by the quite sincere strain of his mind
in the direction of spiritual things for
under sudden temptation back rushed his
being with the greater rigor into its
natural channel on the whole had he not
been a Puritan he would have been a Don
Juan in an instant Rachael's weight was
hanging upon his neck he kissing her
with passion after this she said to him
but you were only doing this out of pity
Walter tell the truth you're in love
with Annie he liked Peter tumbled at
once into a fib that's what you say you
are she insisted filled with the Bliss
of the fib bah I'm not
never was you're the girl for me when
they went home they entered the house at
different times she first he waiting
twenty minutes in the street the house
was small so the sister slept together
in the second floor front room Walter in
the second floor back
mrs. Evans in the first floor back the
first floor front being the drawing-room
the girls therefore generally went to
bed together and that night as they
undressed there was a row first along
silence then Rachel to say something
pointed to some new gloves of Inez
asking how much did you give for those
money and kind words replied Annie this
was the beginning well there's no need
to be rude about it said Rachel she was
happy in Paradise and despised Annie
that night still said Annie after a
silence of ten minutes before the mirror
still I should never run after a man
like that I'd
first I haven't the least idea what
you're talking about replied Rachel you
have I should be ashamed of myself if I
were you talk away you're a little fool
it's you throwing yourself at the head
of a man who doesn't care for you what
can you call yourself rachel laughed
happily yet dangerously don't bother
yourself my girl she said think of going
out every night to meet a man in that
way look here it's too disgusting of you
girl is it you can't deny that you were
with mr. Tiger tonight that I wasn't
it's false anyone can see it by the joy
in your face well suppose I was what
about it but a woman should be decent I
think a woman should be able to command
her feelings and not expose herself like
that
believe me it gives me the creeps all
over to think of nevermind
don't be jealous my girl the gentle
Annie flamed jealous of you there isn't
any need you know not yet but I'm not
there will never be need do you take mr.
tiger for a raving lunatic I should go
and have some false teeth put in first
if I were you
thus did Annie drop to the rock bed of
vulgarity but she knew it to be
necessary in order to touch Rachel as
with a white-hot wire on her very nerve
of anguish and in fact at those words
Rachel's face resembled white iron while
she cried out never mind my teeth it
isn't the teeth a man looks at a man
knows a finally built woman when he sees
her not like a little dumpy Podge thank
you you were very polite replied Annie
browbeaten by an intensity fiercer than
her own but still it's nonsense Rachel
to talk of my being jealous of you I
knew mr. Tiger six months before you and
you won't know him much longer
either for I don't want to have mother
disgraced here and this is no fit place
for him to lodge in I can easily make
him leave it soon at this thing Rachel
flew with minute or palm over Annie's
cheek ready to strike
you dared you anything to make him go
away I'll tear your little nanny winked
flinched uttered a sob no more fight
left in her so for two weeks the
situation lasted only after that night
so intense screw the bitterness between
the sisters that Annie moved down to the
first floor back sleeping now with mrs.
Evans who dimly wondered as for Walter
meanwhile his heart was divided within
him
he loved Danny he was fascinated and
mesmerized by Rachel in another age and
country he would have married both every
day he came to a different resolve not
knowing what to do one thing was evident
a wedding ring would be necessary and he
purchased one uncertain for which of the
girls look here lass he said to Annie in
the train coming home let us put a stop
to this the boss doesn't seem to be in a
hurry about that raise
so suppose we get spliced and be done
privately rather your mom's sister
mustn't know not just yet a while and
you will still keep on living at the
house well of course for the time being
she looked up into his face and smiled
it was settled but two nights afterwards
he met Rachel on his way home from a
prayer meeting at first he was honest
and distant but then committed the
incredible weakness of going with her
for a walk among the squares and ended
by winning from her an easily granted
promise of marriage on the same terms as
those arranged with Annie when the next
day at lunchtime he put his foot on the
threshold of the registrar's office to
give notice he was still in a state of
agonized indecision as to the name which
he should couple with his own when the
official said now the name of the other
party
Walter hesitated shuffled with his feet
then answered
Rachel Evans not till he was again in
the street did he remember that Rachel
was the name of both the girls and at
liberty of choice between them still
remained to him now from the day of
notice to the day of wedlock an interval
of twenty-one clear days must by law
elapsed and Walter though weak enough to
inform both the sisters of the step he
had taken was careful to give them only
a vague idea of the date fixed his once
clear conscience meanwhile was
grievously troubled his feet in a net he
feared to speak to God and went drifting
like flotsam on the river of chants and
chants alone it was which at last cast
him upon the land the fifth day before
the marriage was a bank holiday and he
had arranged with Rachel to go out with
her that day to Hyde Park she to wait
for him at an arranged spot at two
o'clock at two then at a street corner
stood Rachel waiting twirling her
parasol walking a little in returning
Walter however did not appear and what
could have happened was beyond her
divination had he misunderstood or
missed her though incredible it was the
only thing to think to Hyde Park at any
rate she went alone feeling desolate and
ennui in the vague hope of their meeting
him what had happened was this Walter
had been halfway toward the rendezvous
with Rachel when he was met in the
street by Annie who had gone to spend
the day with a married friend at Stroud
Greene but had returned owing to the
husband's illness seeing Walter her face
lit up with smiles
Harry's down with he influenza she said
so I couldn't stay and bore poor Ethel
where are you going for the first time
since his conversion twelve years before
Walter with a high flush now consciously
lied only to the schoolroom he said to
hunt for something well I'm open to be
taken out if any kind friend will be so
kind
she said fondly now he had that morning
vowed to himself to Wed Rachel and by
this vow he now again vowed to be bound
all the more reason why for the last
time he should take out any come along
then old girl he gaily said where shall
we go let's go to Hyde Park said Annie
and to Hyde Park they went Walter ever
and anon stabbed by the bitter memory of
waiting Rachel at five o'clock the two
were walking along the north bank of the
serpentine westward toward a two arched
bridge which is also pierced by a third
narrow arch over the bank to this narrow
arch since it was drizzling they were
making for shelter when Rachel a person
of the keenest vision sighted them from
the South Bank she was frantic at once
Annie who was supposed to be at Stroud
green what treachery this then was why
she ran panting along the bank toward
the bridge than over at northward and
now heard the two under the arch who
stood there talking of the wedding
unfortunately just there was a block of
masonry which prevented Rachel from
leaning directly over the arch to listen
yet the necessity to hear was absolute
so she ran back clear of the masonry and
bent far over the parapet outwards and
sideways toward the arch straining neck
body ears and anyone looking into those
staring eyes then would have
comprehended the doctrine of the fairy
and soul
but she was at a disadvantage heard only
murmurs and was that a kiss further and
further forth she strained and now
suddenly with a cry she was in the water
where it was shallow near the bank in
the fall her head struck upon a stone in
the mud for three days she screamed
continuously the name of Walter filling
the street with it calling him hers only
on the third night in the midst of a
frightful crisis of cries she suddenly
died Oh Rachel don't say you were dead
cried Annie over her the death occurred
two days before the marriage day and on
the next Walter well wounded said to
Annie this knocks our little affair on
the head of course
Annie was silent then with a pout she
said I don't see why after all it was
her own fault entirely
why should we suffer for the feud
between the sisters had become cruel as
death and it outlasted death Annie on
the subject of Rachel and Walter being
no longer a gentle girl but marble
without respect or pity and so in spite
of the trepidations and hesitancy of
Walter the marriage took place even
while Rachel lay stretched on the bed in
the second floor front of number
thirteen the ceremony did not however
transpire without hitch in omen it was
necessary first of all for Walter to
forewarn Annie that he had given notice
of her to the Registrar by her second
name of Rachel a mad looking proceeding
that was almost the cause of a rupture
which nothing but Walters most ardent
pleadings could steer him clear of at
any rate it was to Rachel and not to
Annie that he was as a matter of fact
after all married after the ceremony
performed at their lunch time they
returned to business together in Little
Britain at ten o'clock the same night as
he was going up to bed she ran after him
and in the passage that was a long
furtive kiss their last on earth twelve
o'clock he whispered intensely she held
up her forefinger one oh say twelve she
did not answer but true her palm
playfully across his cheek meaning
consent for mrs. Evans was an inveterate
ly heavy sleeper he went up and careful
to leave his door a little ajar he
extinguished his candle and went to bed
in the apartment nearby lay stark in the
dark with
learn in eternal eyelids and drowsy brow
the dead Walter could not but think of
this presents close at hand well poor
girl he sighed poor Rachel well well
his ways in the sea after all and his
path in the great deep and his footsteps
are not known then he thought of Annie
the little wife but instead of Annie
that was Rachel the two women fought
vehemently for his thought and ever the
Dead was stronger than the living
instead of Annie that was Rachel
and again Rachel at last he could hear
12:00 strike from a steeple and sat up
in bed listening eagerly for the door to
open or a footfall on the floor a little
clock ticked in the room and in the flue
of the chimney was a sigh of the wind
just audible suddenly she was intensely
with him
filling the chamber from nowhere he had
heard no footstep no opening of the door
yet certainly she was with him now all
suddenly close to him over him talking
breathlessly to him his first sensation
was a shuddering which strongly shook
him from head to foot like the
shuttering of Russian cold she held him
down by the shoulders was stretched at
length on the bed over him and the room
seemed full of her rustling and rushing
very strange like starched muslins
rushing out in stormy agitation she was
speaking to to him in a breathless haste
whimpering a secret gibberish which
whimpered like a pup for passion about
love in its definition and about the
soul and the worm and eternity and the
passion of death and the nuptials of the
tomb and the lust and hollowness of the
void and he too was speaking whispering
through his pattering teeth sang Rachel
Annie I mean my girl your ma will hear
Rachel don't shush now but even while he
kept up this shush dear shush now he was
conscious of the invasion of a strange
rage of such a strength as if energy was
being vehemently pumped into him from
some behemoth omnipotence the form above
him he could hardly discern the room was
so dark but he felt that her garment was
flowing forth from her neck in a
continuous flutter and the rustling of
the starch of a thousand shrouds like
the outflow of a pennant and wind and
the quivering gauze seemed now to swell
and fill the chamber and now to sink
again to the size of a woman
and ever the Rhapsody of love and death
went on mixed with the chattered Rachael
Annie I mean of Walter till suddenly he
was involved in an embrace so horrible
felt himself encompassed by a might so
intolerable that his soul fainted within
him he sank back thoughts spun and
failed in darkness beneath the spell of
that lullaby he muttered receive my
spirit after two days Walter still
unconscious died his disfigured body
they placed in a grave not far from
Rachael's
[Music]
you
you